thank you all for coming it's great to
see you and I hope that today's talk
gives you some great ideas and I hope I
can learn something from you but as well
in getting your feedback so i have been
working at the intersection of game
design and social media for about 15
years and recently in the last year and
a half or so I've gotten particularly
interested in co-op and that's why I'm
choosing to talk about it now my current
clients are all forms of co-op design
some of them are game design clients
like crowdstar who makes mobile games
for females I'm also working with
IndieGoGo who is number two to
Kickstarter working the crowd sourced
area and what I'm finding is that more
and more people in the world are
realizing that the big opportunity both
in games in a social media is in
creating effective co-op systems so I'm
going to share some of what I'm seeing
and why I think this is an exciting
opportunity so first off let's start
with what is a game the very broad
definition and my preference rather than
getting into arguments about semantics
is to simply define how I'm using the
term so that it's very clear and the
first thing is that games mean different
things to different people in particular
against zero-sum and nonzero-sum gaming
so this is a definition for a game that
is taken from a textbook called rules of
play came out in 1995 good book but this
definition is when I started working in
the industry which was around that time
I was very widely accepted a system
where Kate players engaged in a conflict
with rules and a quantifiable outcome
sounds good so that it turns out
actually is a good definition of a
zero-sum game zero-sum game in simple
terms is a game where the people in it
are framed as opponents okay if I win
you lose there are winners and losers in
a zero-sum game there's usually a
limited resource that's divided up among
the winners sometimes winner-take-all so
so for example any head-to-head battle
is a zero-sum game any rank ordered
competition whether it's you know
playing piano at a recital when you're a
kid or the Olympics is a zero-sum game
most gambling games or zero-sum games
although often you're playing against
the house not against other players wore
simulations polo chess go all zero-sum
games so it's a big world of zero some
gaming big rich world however as I
worked in the industry working on titles
like the sims and rock band in
particular the sims I realized that this
definition didn't describe accurately
the biggest hits that I've been
associated with and I thought okay well
the definition needs to be different or
broader because that definition that I
showed you does not describe the sims
there's no quantifiable outcome doesn't
describe ultima online either another
game i worked on so i came up with my
own definition for a game that's enable
me to embrace IndieGoGo as a gaming
platform for example and to me a game is
a structured experience with one rules
it's important that there be rules goals
and a sense of progress that's fun to
play and that certainly describes the
sense and many other games but if you
look around you and you think about the
excitement around gamification and how
people think about gamifying everyday
life etc and you use this definition I
find it helpful to frame what you're
trying to do and it turns out that the
finishing is pretty close to defining a
non zero sum game in a non zero sum game
the simple way to think about it is
rather than it framing the players as
opponents the players are framed as
partners we win together we also lose
together okay so some good examples of
that would be double dutch many
playground games even if they have
outcomes like hopscotch they're really
more about playing together you can't
play it by yourself that wouldn't be
much fun dictionary is a really good
example of non zero sum game mechanics
in pictionary or in draw something which
is online mobile pictionary you win
together you use
you lose together you and your partner
your job is to come up with a good
enough drawing that the other person can
guess it and then you both win and if
you don't you both lose that's a great
example if you want to try and remember
this karate is basically a personal
progression game and there are karate
competitions that have zero some
mechanics but it's fundamentally a
supportive game at least the way it's
expressed in American culture that you
cheer on other people and together you
can all do well and a really good
example to of collaborative system game
mechanic is say a charity walk where
your goal isn't to beat someone else so
much unless there's a leaderboard that's
introduced your goal is that the more
people you can get involved in
supporting you the better everybody does
together it's very much a we experience
versus a me against you experience so
that's game theory 101 so so what why
should you care about this why is that
an important thing to understand well to
help you understand why I want to tell
you i'm going to zoom out for a minute
and tell you what's going on in the
games industry this is my bread and
butter where I work and in the last few
years particularly the last three years
the games industry has been massively
disrupted in terms of who the audience
is what's going on with the kind of
games that are succeeding and that's why
you should care because this is also
trickling out into other industries
three key trends the first is ubiquitous
connected devices smartphones tablets
and also portable computers this is a
major platform disruption for the games
industry games industry grew up on
consoles connected consoles and mobile
consoles that's not where the growth is
anymore so if you take a look at this
chart from digital capital that bottom
area that's consoles it's flat to
declining if you look at the upper areas
you got online mobile and pc that's
where all the growth is particularly in
mobile so
it's not the biggest sector but it's the
sector that's growing and it's growing
in fact even more rapidly than this
chart which was done a year ago would
indicate yes these are all revenue what
about in terms of number of players
there's many of these things you know
they have different revenue models data
on hand the tracks along you do in
general get more revenue from core
gamers per person that's a general trend
across the industry but it's a rapidly
changing thing because in the last six
to eight months the free-to-play
microtransaction model has become a huge
ravaged enter revenue generator on
mobile and so what you get is the same
dynamics that we saw on facebook where
you get whales and you might be
monetizing five to seven percent of your
audience but you're monetizing them in a
big way but it's it's a it's a rat it's
across the board League of Legends is an
anomaly it's a pc-based game but it's
big it's a free-to-play game they
monetize forty percent of their players
so that's that's kind of an anomaly that
one of those figures but I'd say that
they track this the bottom line is that
the console industry the console sector
of the gaming industry is in decline and
the addressable market is a comparison
to the overall gaming market is
shrinking the addressable market in
mobile tablet and PC is growing meaning
the people who have a device that you
could sell games do here's another
interesting chart a little out of date
but it shows you in Justin mobile what's
going on and the punchline of this is
that smartphones are eating the lunch of
dedicated gaming consoles and that shows
you what's happening just between 2009
and 2011 and market share and that trend
is continuing
the second disruption that's going on in
the games industry is the player base
it's connected to this change in
platforms okay but it's not exactly the
same what's happening mainstream all
ages both genders that's the market now
that's major audience disruption couple
of stats the fastest growing demographic
on Facebook is women 55 plus and a
recent m2 research recently ran a survey
and found that 93% of kids in the 8 to
13 age group play games online a lot of
them are playing free pc games some of
them are playing on facebook but that's
basically almost everybody so what does
this mean for gaming gaming is
traditionally marketed to and made gains
for 18 to 24 maybe 18 to 35 year old men
and certainly when i started in gaming
that was the market the sims blew that
out by the way the sims was almost
cancelled five times before it ever
launched the executives that EA thought
this thing will never work who would
play this thing turns out that women
played it and that's the trend that I'm
really talking about so I think you
could fuse thinking how all these work
together you can start to see why
nonzero-sum gaming is such an
interesting topic the third trend is
what I call mutual entertainment it's
very tightly related to user generated
content or ugc and this is content
disrupting so we've got platform
disruption audience disruption and
content disruption what I mean by this
is people are entertaining each other
more and more online and their people
are becoming accustomed to getting some
of their entertainment from other people
not just from crafted content made by
professionals for example here's a
Nielsen services from last year and if
you let this is the monthly hours for
Internet users and what you can see here
is gaining Wow greatings way up there
even more so than email but it's dwarfed
by social networking and blogging social
networking and blogging is mutual
entertainment that's people entertaining
each other right so that tells you part
of what's going on here instagram that's
another example Instagram is a platform
for people to entertain each other right
so that has continues that big usage
although they've had some drop offs
we've got wine we've got you know
various new things the punch line here
is that some of the entertainment hours
and dollars that are associated with
those hours that were perhaps ten years
ago spent with games movies TV are now
being taken up with mutual entertainment
and platforms that deliver mutual
entertainment yes try gravitation
network is a vehicle for side
presentation or social oppression rather
than mutual entertainment good I may be
on Facebook because I want to make
myself look good sometimes sir yeah well
i don't know i mean i think absolutely
that's another part of it i think that
identity development you know social you
know constructed identity development is
deeply a part of mutual entertainment i
think they're intertwined is what I
actually think but what I'm talking
about is your this is the thing I'm
talking about you're standing in line
somewhere you're on the train you're
waiting for something you've got 10
minutes between classes and you pull out
your phone what do you do do you play
game do you take a picture do you read
facebook what do you do that's what I'm
talking about I'm talking about the
competition for you for that for your
mind share and spending your time and if
you're not playing a game that's an
opportunity loss for the gaming industry
so that's what I'm talking about is from
the user experience point of view from
how their people are spending their time
and the reality is that
there are a lot more opportunities for
people to spend their time browsing a
Facebook feed browsing in it bends to
graham feed browsing Twitter looking at
vine videos and that's time not spent on
crafted media and that's why it's an
important trend I also know this is an
important trend from all of the calls
and inquiries I get from the gaming
industry asking me to help them figure
out how to build ugc and ugc generating
systems into their games and into the
meta games surround their games it's
just like ridiculous they know this is a
trend as well and they see it and they
see what's cannibalizing their industry
and they're trying to embrace it okay
another example here is this is the draw
something screen that makes it really
clear that this is a non zero sum game
where you win together and you lose
together but again draw something which
was a craze and now it's gone is mutual
entertainment there's a little bit of
content and there's a dictionary but
what is that it's the same thing as
pictionary right its people entertaining
each other with their creativity and for
those of you interested in systems that
promote creativity and allow people to
be creative this is a golden age because
there's more and more people that want
to do that and that are now accustomed
to the idea that they might be able to
do that in a digital system so there's a
few things that I've learned in working
in games that relate to the mindset of
zero-sum games and nonzero-sum games
what and recently I worked on a startup
called hapa Phi which is now in early
beta that caused me to dig deeply into
the literature on happiness the stuff
that's been proven in labs and the one
of the most robust findings you see it
cross culturally and you see it across
different labs replicated is that social
comparison leads to unhappiness it makes
people feel less happy subjectively and
now
zero-sum games are all about social
comparison now I'm not saying zero-sum
games are bad I'm not saying that we
should get rid of them but if what
you're trying to do is figure out how to
encourage people to actually feel
happier which is something I'm very
interested in as a game designer then
this is a good study to keep in mind and
to know about what we also see as robust
of a cross-cultural finding is that
playing together the sense of
companionship and mutual benefit that
you get from playing together and
building social relationships through
that play leads to happiness in all
kinds of different ways the other thing
excuse me that I learned through both my
game design experience and also the
happiness research that I did was that
it's very simple different players like
different kinds of engagement there is
not a one-size-fits-all not everybody is
going to be motivated by League of
Legends a lot of people don't like
combat on the other hand a lot of people
really need the spark of competition to
get them interested and that so there is
absolutely not a one-size-fits-all so as
designers and I'm very much a
practitioner you know I'm out there
working on real stuff that ships so as
designers any of you that aspire to that
are already doing that knowing who your
players are is always always always
where you start you know if you ask our
badges effective should I use zero
summer nonzero-sum you always start with
saying who's playing how do they like to
interact do they like to interact in a
helpful way do they like to interact in
a competitive way but in general this is
just a simplification but in general
women are both socialized and have a
natural interest in helping each other
when they're playing there's you can
easily come up with counter examples but
in general if you look at the activity
cross-culturally through history that
women like to engage in the structured
activities many of them are nonzero some
men in general if you again look cross
culturally really enjoy the zero-sum
competitive dynamics of seeing who's on
top if you look at the way children play
cross-culturally just naturally in a
playground in a setting the way that
little boys play and you know you can go
and find lots of info about this there's
a book called you just don't understand
by Deborah Tannen that's a linguistics
book that lays this out beautifully and
has all the citations in general little
boys will form packs and then seek to
figure out the rank ordering within the
pack who's the alpha dog who's on top
it'll either be through academics in
some settings it will be through mostly
who's strongest who's tallest etc etc
that's how they play that's very natural
girls on the other hand will engage in
relationship building and rather than
using the blunt edged weapon of I'm
stronger than you I can beat you up
there for on the Alpha they will use
relationships as their weapons of choice
and it's much more subtle but the I'm
your friend today I'm not your friend
tomorrow is how girls play and those
groupings of friendship is how they're
working out who's got status within
their groups so that doesn't mean it's
pervasively true but it means in general
that's a good guess as a starting point
for coming to understand your users so
there's something called jot Bartels
player types that you may hear about if
you look at gamification it's almost
always misused and it came about so John
Richard Bartle was one of the first
creators of muds which are the text
precursors of games like World of
Warcraft and he observed through working
on three different meds with three
different themes that these prior types
kept emerging even when the month had
different themes so he called them
player types there's achievers explorers
socializers and killers and they're
defined by what runs through your mind
the first time that you come in are you
looking when you come into a new
environment do you look at it and say
what can I achieve do come in and say
who's here what do I know about them who
has a lot of relationships what's the
gossip do you come in and say what's all
the content what can be explored is
there a secret dungeon I can find you
know what's the lore that would be the
Explorer type and then killers or
griefers trolls people that come in and
say what can I mess with who can I mess
with how can i hack the system and so if
you're designing an MMO or system like a
mud or an MMO you will see these player
types pretty reliably and I've worked on
a number of MMOs however they were
designed to work particularly to express
what was going on in MMOs and if you try
and apply them to banking software for
instance they might not work so well so
and you can go and find a link to
richard bottle himself saying i can't
believe all these idiots are taking my
failure types and applying them to these
things where they have no reason
applying them so on the next time you
see some gamification guru telling you
about bartels player types as being the
answer now you know how to think about
that person more effectively so here's a
quote from him so basically points
badges levels leaderboards those things
those apply to achievers but it turns
out even achievers many p it turns out
in my own work many people that are
achievers there's people that enjoy
collaboration achievement through
collaboration versus people that enjoy
competition and achievement through
competition so through years of working
with clients and trying to give them
useful tools I came up with a different
classification scheme that I use all the
time this is also not carved in stone I
give this to my clients i'm going to
give it to you now you might find you're
working on something where this doesn't
work great change it alter it to meet
your own but it's a good starting place
for social media so it's i define it as
for verbs rather than player type my
experience has been that trying to put
people in the player types is not as
useful as identifying the key verbs that
are motivating to your players and then
identifying the
in the experience you're delivering at
which those verbs are most relevant so
the four verbs are compete collaborate
express and explore their similar to
bottle but their specific to looking at
what actually happens in social media
system so one thing to know is that the
key social actions that you put into
your system your digital system are
going to set the tone so for instance
here you see that if you click on this
player this is I think this is
poptropica if anyone know poptropica
anyway I think this is poptropica so
what can you do you can if you click on
someone you can friend them you can
battle them or you can chat those are
pretty different things battle okay who
can tell me is battle zero-sum or
nonzero sum can you and tell me hmm good
okay you get a badge now I'm just
kidding chat is chat zero summer
nonzero-sum as a mechanic what is it
right it's a mutual thing you can't like
it if you want to chat it takes two
people and then if you either both want
to chat and you're chatting or if one
doesn't want to play your you're done
right so even though it's very simple
that's a nonzero-sum mechanic and friend
obviously a nonzero-sum mechanic so
something very practical and immediate
that you can take away from this is to
think about the actions that you're
enabling in your digital system map them
to that chart see what is it an explorer
action or be an explorer action you have
searched you have you know browse you
have you know just explore can be in
action in them itself what are the
compete actions taunt challenge win beat
what are the collaboration actions
helped give
end chat right those are all gestures of
collaboration and what would be the
Express self-expression actions create
design customise those are the actions
of self-expression yes the overwrought
example consider a chocolate like
chatter that was launched as something
that was nonzero-sum that we're actually
just chatting with each other and then
you have a son who effectively comes in
it for a zero-sum purpose that is just
grieving more or less and it destroys
the social fighter of the sides mom is
is your claim here that this seems weird
right that I can shower battle given the
design language is the wrestlers thing
so I are you trying to make claim that
they can't coexist or that day no they
so the reason that that happens and that
will happen in everything like Charlie
here's the general principle that
explains what you just said about
chatroulette anytime that you give
people an experience where the purpose
of the experience is not directed and
clear they will co-opt it for their own
aims every single time so a example that
is maybe a little bit more family
friendly than chatroulette is minecraft
minecraft broke every rule of game
design most people in gaming thought
minecraft was ridiculous it would never
be a hit and now they're trying to copy
it the reason that minecraft is so
powerful one of the reasons is that
there's just enough structure but
minecraft never tells you except in
survival mode but if you playing
minecraft in creative mode it never
tells you what your goals are you define
your own goals that was the same with
second life too but second life didn't
take off like minecraft took off for
lots of reasons so you define your own
goals than that so do people play
minecraft collaboratively yes do people
play minecraft competitively yes do
people play minecraft to self explore
yes to some people grief well it depend
on all the same place what's happened in
Minecraft is that the way that they in
mented local servers the server
structure let people set up servers that
had a specific goal for instance you can
go to a hunger games minecraft server
and there you're playing the hunger
games and you can also go to the let's
rebuild Venice in the 1400s server and
there you jump in and it's fundamentally
collaborative right in The Hunger Games
it's fundamentally competitive so it's a
blank it's sort of a blank canvas but
you can use in these different ways same
with chatroulette if chatroulette had
been you know an enterprise
collaboration software thing it would
have been used in a very different way
but very basic flexible systems unless
you as the user and that user and you is
the owner tell people what it's for and
reinforce that with mechanics people
will use it in a variety of ways and
you'll see that like everywhere all the
time you know it let's say let's say
somebody throws a party an open party I
you know somewhere on campus and just as
everybody come and you know the purpose
of this party everybody just come
anybody come and there's free beer do
you think there's likely that people
might come and like cause some problems
or people that you didn't want to come
my yeah because you're not saying
versus if you throw a party and say okay
this is the purpose of the party this is
who we'd like people to come but this is
who should come this is who shouldn't
come we don't want you here you'll get a
completely different outcome so what the
creator of a digital system puts forth
as the rules remember when i define
games and i said rules is one of the key
things structured experience with rules
and goals that's fun those rules are a
huge part of what will make something we
hate happen in a certain way so I mean I
just I've observed that all over the
place so sometimes when people are like
well we have this open system when we
hoped for this behavior but we got this
behavior it's like why don't you try
telling people what they should expect
and like just that can really change
things
so so that so here's so here's the
question what are your defining social
actions ask yourself this map your
actions and then think about how that
relates to the motivations of your
players so here we have those examples
Express compete collaborating and
explore I'll put this online as well so
you guys can not worry about having to
copy everything down but this as an
exercise can be a big aha moment for you
as a designer because let's say that
you're targeting females and you have a
bunch of stuff in the compete area and
not much in collaborate you might go hmm
maybe that's why you know I'm getting
this behavior so it's very useful to
just be explicit about what you're
defining social actions are map that to
the motivation of your players and if
you don't have a good map change it so
you do have a good map so now let's talk
about collaboration in particular so
that's some basic background stuff I've
been fascinated with minecraft I don't
know how many of you know about what's
going on with education minecraft is
being used now worldwide by middle
school educators to teach collaboration
in the classroom which blows my mind and
so I've been really digging in and
studying what's going on with Minecraft
and why minecraft why did it take off
why not these other things there's a lot
of reasons some that's pricing no
monthly fee a lot of educators used to
teach with wow world of warcraft switch
to minecraft because of them a monthly
fee but it's also that just enough
structure so let's look at those four
verbs and look how minecraft implements
can you explore in Minecraft absolutely
it's the first thing you do you just
like you can explore randomly generated
landscapes that's one of the things you
can always create a new landscape to
explore you're not stuck with something
all the time you can go to a new server
and check out new stuff there's the
exploration is essentially endless can
you compete yes but what's built into
the game is very interesting what's
built in the game is not competing with
other players like you mind and say
league of legend
it's competing with the environment the
competition and minecraft happens during
the onboarding which is you compete with
the system to survive the night am i
doing so hopefully you figure out how to
build a shelter so you don't get eaten
by monsters can you express yourself in
Minecraft yeah it's a huge part of the
appeal people express themselves both by
building structures inside I have a
six-year-old daughter and when she was
five she used to watch her brother
playing her who was 13 then minecraft
and she got really into it and then
minecraft for the iPad came out so I got
it for her and she first of all
immediately could use it from having
watched her brother the first thing she
did was build her own house and she had
to show me and she had to show her dad
and it's just that primal thing of look
what I made that is so powerful in
Minecraft but that leads into the fourth
which is the collaboration so there's
huge collaboration going on in Minecraft
there isn't a single badge or quest or
mission of any kind that tells you to
collaborate unless it's been layered on
by a third-party mod or by that someone
who's running one of the local servers
just the sheer nature of Minecraft
encourages collaboration the fact that
you can log on to a server the fact that
there are bigger challenges than you can
just do yourself you go to youtube and
look at Minecraft videos you go and you
do a search and image search and you'll
see these elaborate structures and if
you've you're interested in creation you
say huh that's cool how could I build
that while it turns out you really can't
build it by yourself unless you have
unlimited time so what minecraft does
just by the kind of nature of how it's
built and how its evolved and how much
its expressed on social media is it
innately presents challenges to you that
are bigger than what you could pull off
yourself so that's an important point
tuck that away now let's talk about
Kickstarter I've also been fascinated
with Kickstarter and following it I
think it's a really important evolution
to me Kickstarter is a platform that
enables short-term time limited
collaborative games every campaign on
kickstarter
think about it as a collaborative game
why is it that it's structured there's a
wind state you either get funder you
don't there's rules and it's encouraging
and allowing people to band together to
accomplish something they could not
accomplish on their own that's that's
what it is so it's a very powerful
platform and it's going through troubles
there's definitely a backlash a lot of
people aren't getting their perks that
they signed up for but it's as you
probably all know a really important
trend and overall crowdsourcing you know
collaboration in this style i think is
only going to get bigger so let's see
what's going on can you compete and
Kickstarter yes but once again you're
not competing with other people you're
not even competing with other projects
you're competing with the system the
system says how much do you want to
raise this is how much time you have to
raise it you get the whole amount if you
raise it you get nothing if you don't
you're competing with the system which
gives it teeth it gives it excitement
right and it drives urgency time and
resource constraints Drive urgency can
you explore Kickstarter is an amazing
exploration platform you can explore
upcoming projects you can go on there if
you're bored and browse a few videos
they just release their mobile app which
makes it even easier and the Kickstarter
is even added a feature I'm not sure if
it's still there I know they added a
feature just let you just watch video
after video after video of these
passionate people explaining why their
project deserves your support so a lot
of people think about what I said about
mutual entertainment this is a mutual
entertainment platform Kickstarter's not
making these videos people regular users
are making the videos to ask for funding
but they're also entertaining other each
other and they're entertaining people
you don't have to contribute to
Kickstarter to get value out so in
kickstarter self-expression and
collaboration or bound up together in a
really interesting way so you can
certainly express yourself by creating a
project that's like a deep
Russian I'm a movie maker I have this
vision or I'm a movie maker I've made a
small film I need distribution or I'm an
artist or on a musician and now Gaines
has actually been a huge area for them
it made I think the most money of all of
their sectors last year by the way last
year Kickstarter raised almost three
times as much as was given out by the
NEA and grants just to give you a sense
about what's really going on so you can
express yourself by creating a project
that you can also express yourself by
backing projects on Kickstarter you are
what you back if you go to someone's
profile on Kickstarter what you can see
and you see it here is all the projects
they've backed and here's my friend
Andrew he's back 61 projects dude is
really into it and you can also see that
little pie chart that's the sectors that
he's back if you mouse over it you would
see art movies music games gadgets so
he's he's back more than jeez not just
back in games he's doing a bunch of
things this is his identity on
Kickstarter and by doing that
Kickstarter makes even browsing
someone's profile interesting and
another way to discover projects so so
you collapse you immediately are
collaborating not just with the creator
of the project but with everyone else
who backed it you've got a sense of
kinship with them you all cared enough
to back the same project so that's the
collaboration piece now let's talk about
folded how many of you have heard of
folded good okay so how many of you know
about what actually led to the big
breakthrough in folden with emergent
teams ok now I'm going to tell you about
that then so I won't bother to give you
the whole spiel about folded is this and
that folded is a protein folding game
that crowdsources protein folding
basically figuring out the key to how
this protein folds in order to in
general solve disease issues and develop
drugs that would combat particular
diseases so the really interesting story
to me who's you know
cest with collaboration with full of it
is what actually happened with the
team's full that did not launch as a
collaborative game it launched with
leaderboards and single-player
competition that's how they launched
because why because it's much easier to
do that than to design collaboration
it's just much more straightforward what
they're really doing is as I said
they're crowdsourcing science big top
real problems remember when I mentioned
that if you give people problems that
are bigger than they can solve alone
that motivates collaboration well hold
it is a great example of that so there's
a couple of interesting things that
happened the folded cookbook is a
repository of protein folding rules or
heuristics you know if you confront a
protein with this particular
configuration try this try this these
are the things to try the cookbook was
originally created by the creators of
folded and what happened was over time
they started to open it up to the very
best players so that they could actually
extend the rules of the system itself
with their input that's ug so they
integrated ugc into the rules of the
system and that became a badge of honor
to have your stuff in the cookbook so
again let's look at those four verbs so
in fold it you absolutely compete with
the system to solve real scientific
problems that's connected to the real
world so you're not in this game world
that doesn't have impact if you actually
solved problems you would have a real
impact on science that's very motivating
for the kind of people that play folded
there's always new puzzles and roll sets
to explore they're always giving you
there's contests there's new puzzles
there's new things in the cookbook that
you can evaluate get the back on it's a
very rich exploratory environment you
can collaborate with others to solve
hard problems now there was a very
famous in 2012 folded announced that a
team of elite players had actually
solved an HIV puzzle that had stumped
scientists for 10 years which is amazing
but and people said Oh games can do this
games because that well it's not
actually the game that did it what
actually happened and this is a video
you can see it on youtube and these are
the elite players and this video is
about the story of what happened does
what happened there were players who are
like some of the top players they were
into it they had the time they've been
playing for a while and there were
puzzles they just couldn't fall so they
started sending them around between each
other they felt organized okay into a
group and they said maybe we should ban
together this is just really hard and
they started sending the puzzles around
the creators of fold it responded by
enabling a team structure in the game so
they didn't come up with that themselves
they were responding to what they saw
happening already among their players by
the way that's a really good thing look
at what your players are doing and
double down on it make it easier for
them remove the friction for them that's
just in general a good development
policy and so then they built that in
and then they added the you know the
hooks into the cookbook and these elite
players are who actually solve this
thing the important thing to take away
is that one person couldn't do it on
their own and they self organized that
was that didn't come from folded
creators and then this is a quote from
the movie you don't find many soloists
among the top scorers meaning that the
people that played folded a lot figured
out that the play better they needed to
collaborate because the problems were so
hard there's also fold it's not
fundamentally about self-expression in
the way that minecraft is but the fact
that elite that players can add to the
cookbook can add the rules of the
cookbook gives people that are into it a
mode of self-expression completely
analogous to modding in Minecraft or
call of duty or any of the other modern
communities that you gamers may be more
familiar with so that was the area of
self-expression and its really taken off
to the point where they implemented a
whole rating system see up there it says
who created this this is a recipe this
is what the cookbook looks like and
other people can say oh I tried this and
it worked out or oh this sucks you know
you don't know what you're doing mobile
buff so now you've got this
back loop where you're actually
crowdsourcing quality control with
everybody with all the players so this
is just the tip of the iceberg with
what's going on with collaboration and
just from that I want to give you three
emerging best practices to start your
thinking about this the first is big
meaningful challenges inspire collective
action every one of these examples I
gave you shows that so if you're
designing something and you want to
inspire collaboration think about
offering challenges to your player base
that they just can't solve themselves
whether you do it through trickery like
you each have a piece of a puzzle and
you have to get together to solve the
puzzle that's fine but you can also do
it in the more unstructured minecraft
way of inspiring people with something
that they could do that would make them
want to ban together and then making
sure they have the mechanism to do that
so Kickstarter is using Kickstarter is a
great example of that down here fold
it's a great example of that and these
are other examples from minecraft so
that bridge which is a very detailed
cool bridge was done by a team on
private server and this is a bunch of
mods that let people have different
looking characters in Minecraft and you
can see obviously that for people to
play together they need to get together
in and play but modding is one of the
key things that's making minecraft so
long lasting and powerful the second
best practice set up your players to
compete with the system but not each
other so minecraft I'm guessing I don't
have I can't say this is true my guess
is that if minecraft had been released
just with creative mode without survival
mode survival mode is where you compete
with the system creative mode is
freeform resources are unlimited you can
build whatever you want which is more
likes a second line if it had just been
released with creative mode it wouldn't
have been nearly the success
there is an excitement and urgency that
comes with competition but if you can
set it up so that the competition is
with the system and not with other
players you're creating a foundation for
collaboration much more so than if you
set up the competition with players so
think a little less about leaderboards
which is Player to Player competition
very zero-sum mechanic and think more
about what you could do to set up a
competition with the play with the
system ideally a competition with the
system that creates a sense of urgency
and that creates great onboarding and
teachers players what they need to know
that's a best practice so again so
Kickstarter great example of competing
with the system same with Minecraft this
shows you a screenshot of survival mode
and you've got various metrics and you
know you've got a win-lose it's a soft
lose you can come back to life but you
can die which gives all the thing teeth
and the third is a little less obvious
but definitely important which is if you
want to stimulate collaboration see if
you can set up systems that allow
talented enthusiasts to extend your
world to extend your game world to
extend your content so again this is an
example of mods in minecraft mojang
didn't have to build these somebody else
did it's awesome so in general open API
is and modding not appropriate for
everybody but it's a great thing to
enrich the content and to give players
another form of self-expression that is
more even more powerful and has more
impact than just creating content and
then down here with folded the this
principle of letting people spend the
system when I talked about the folded
cookbook which lets these elite players
share their strategies and if it was a
zero-sum vibe and and focus in that
world they wouldn't be sharing their
strategies would they because in a
zero-sum world you don't do that
because those other people are your
opponents remember opponents versus
partners that's the zero-sum nonzero-sum
thing to remember so if you want to
create collaboration you want to set
people up not as opponents but as
partners and so if you let people show
off their knowledge share that which is
what modding is and what that cookbook
extensions are your you're saying
through your mechanics through your
systems we value partnership and
collaboration so to me when I look at
the world of gaming I see a very rich
set of games that have been developed
that are zero sum games in competitive
games and I see very few really
interesting collaborative games but more
and more on the horizon and as my
challenge to you I think this is a big
blue ocean opportunity both for research
and academia and also for development in
the world if the inquiries I'm getting
from industry or any indication this is
dramatic co-op gaining is dramatically
on the upswing so what I want to know is
what can you create that's particular to
what you're doing in your special
knowledge and experiences that no one
has ever seen the foreign co-op gaming
and I hope some of you go off and take
that challenge and let me know how it
goes because I would like to learn from
what you do thank you very much
shall we do QA anybody got any questions
or stories to tell no I would just know
I really love the example of folded and
one of the things that I found I do some
surprising was one of the teams that you
insulted issued a monkey virus that has
been published along with the creators
of folded rather than have the team
members listed individually they opted
to have their team name the contender
the actual name of scientific
publication so when you go look out the
paper that crap the protein per month
arrives one of the authors is the
contenders and this notion of like a
social identity as a team as opposed the
individual I editing is a really rich
and interesting issue that Ald is with
the examples we showed us thank you for
sharing that that's a great point and it
really speaks to group identity and the
power of group identity siesta talk with
some of the most dramatically of watched
competitive is outfits I football where
you haven't you and we're part of the
joy in the pleasure is working together
with the team the social interactions
and the friendship and the fellowship
with the team so they're playing against
different teams and your take on I think
it's great you're playing against the
system in some sense we do that when we
make noise other countries we dehumanize
them and there were a bad system but I
think it your idea of incorporating this
anonymous system that doesn't exist in
games is just Wellman I'm glad you
resonate with its her team sports are a
beautiful blend of zero and non-zero
some they just they have both and that's
part of why team sports are so
compelling is that they they have the
they have the good things of both so
thank you for sharing that personal
gaming and then with society there will
be less country on country
I think as long as people are competing
for scarce resources they'll always be
country on country or perceived scarce
resources a lot of the robbery mostly
amazed countries cooperate is an
external threat that threatens them both
I mean just human nature like in
Independence Day that's I mean that's
such a fantasy right it's such a
compelling idea that something would get
all of us to cooperate but you know I
don't really want to go down the path of
saying what I think is going to happen
with war in the future because I don't
actually know but I do see that an
external threat is the best thing to get
people to cooperate now this gentleman
had a question about this is a very
interesting talking pretty much and just
sitting here towards the end I suddenly
realized wow open sources very much like
a game for the way you described it so
as you look at the open source
pacifically the Linux community do you
see things where you go wow they really
took this gaming thing the heart this
could be the bigger or work better or do
you think that just maybe I stumbled
into it but they stumbled to a pretty
good realization of it well enough to
have strong opinion to be honest I think
that the open source community is
complicated I mean I think it's very
open and yet there's also gatekeepers
who have their quirks and that's
probably all I want to say about was
there someone here yes Terry no sir I
did I came back to your points and this
life is how much that is what we're
saying about the wage he should so the
d.school your example I remember want to
exactly on the other thing it says we do
students big challenges they compete
with the system at the end some number
of teams but to continue their projects
not
anyone with jerk any other students
develop projects so in some sense
sucking my fishing but utilizing density
and if these rules work better than the
Tuesday today yes yes so I academics is
already game ified because there's
grades like so I just I have to just
tell you i think the word gamification
is meaningless because it's used so
broadly that's why i don't want it that
i never use it I've been doing this kind
of work for 15 years you know I develop
systems that you would call game if I'd
for ebay in 1997 and I just called it
design to me again it's that it's a tool
belt you know I'm a designer were
incensed any of us who are designers we
have tools we have ux tools we have game
design and they're just tools and you
pull them out as needed for a project so
if they're at the d.school is doing this
and they're fitting in with it again
this isn't like I'm brilliant i came up
with these I'm triangulating across
what's happening in the real world i'm
looking at stuff that's working and i'm
saying why is it working what are the
common threads what are the common
patterns i'm a pattern recognizer in
this sense and these are the patterns i
see and the fact that it's similar to
what the d.school is doing is another
confirmation that this is a powerful set
of patterns but i'm also looking at if
you don't do these what happens and what
happens is it's much harder to get
people to collaborate if you have a
leaderboard and then people come to me
sometimes we're not getting people to
collaborate and i go to their site and
they've got a big old leaderboard there
and I'm like duh please so that's the
other thing is that get people to
compete against the system not against
each other that's where it comes from so
yes and then you so I'm curious about
the title decision I you know me we talk
about design will be sort of sometimes
full contract design and usability and
user thoroughly will take
idea that you've already sore generated
or process and then try to ship off the
rough edges and make it work the way
that you intended when I look at some of
these patterns not just doors but you
know in the in the game design
literature and so on if you write
patterns and and when that happens
sometimes I wonder okay so if we either
back up and say well how do we know that
the High River bit gory deserve
minecraft open new exploration in
creation or with a child I just
connecting to anyone else whether those
things are going to succeed regardless
of whether you apply these patterns that
seems like a really hard problem I
wonder you keep any problem and that's
where vision and risk come in so there's
a great movie about Minecraft called
minecraft the movie and it's like you
eight bucks to buy it online or whatever
bet they followed Mojang in a particular
notch through you know trying it and
developing it and the reality is he had
no idea if it was going to be a hit even
know he was just trying stuff and he was
responding a lot to what people like
they got developed over a long period of
time and it turned into a hit but you
can't reproduce that like I said no none
of us who worked on the sims really knew
if it was going to be a total flop or a
hit nobody knew and it hit a nerve and
so you can't you know all of the this is
how you do a hit game minecraft broke
those rules so there's no one right way
and guess what in five years when
there's 20 copies of minecraft someone's
going to break the rules again and a
bunch of smart executives who grew up
and we're surprised by minecraft ins
that that's never going to happen again
I'm going to get on this are going to
say that would never work and I would
probably say cuz I'll be an old fogey
right I was like that would never work
and we'll all be wrong so there's
absolutely I mean part I think part of
what's happened with the the embracing
of the lean startup in the lean software
movement is to take a more experimental
approach to the
kind of software design and say build
something that's fairly minimal get it
out there and get some feedback and
treat it as if it's a scientific
experiment and learn from the feedback
right okay and yet that rule doesn't
work the Pinterest guy Ben Silverman
said if I had done that I would have
given up on it first didn't work but I
believed in my vision so I went after it
for a year and nobody would send me and
then finally it took off so there's no
one right way but I think you can learn
a lot and then you can have you just use
think that there's either a problem that
needs to be solved a pain point you can
address or a game that would be so fun
to play and then you build it and then
you try it you started working through
it client who is struggling with
collaboration or if I'm creating
something of my own and I have you know
launched my own software as well I would
start with these and then I also have a
framework for designing over time where
I look at the onboarding phase i look at
the habit building phase i look at what
it means to master the system and then i
create loops what i call engagement
loops around those so those are my tools
i use those tools but nothing can
replace a spark of inspiration or a gut
sense and usually that's where people
start but even with game designers like
some people start just like with messing
around with a prototype just like
musicians some musicians start with
lyrics and then they get music added to
it some like elton john's start with
music and then they get lyrics at it you
know at least the stories I've read some
game designers start with messing around
with a prototype and building out from
there some start with an idea and that
they sketch out some start by sketching
out the emotional journey like the
effect journey speaking of journey the
team that did journey who I know very
well they were really upset they have
all these little charts and you can go
to online and see some of these but they
had all these little charts with the
emotional journey very much like a movie
maker would map out an air
and the emotional arcs that they wanted
and that was the guiding light for what
they wanted to deliver and when they did
their test they were measuring it
against that did this illicit the
emotions we were looking for so there's
more than one way to skin a cat so what
I would encourage you is to start with
if you're a programmer great start with
a prototype you know if you're a
designer start with maybe you know a
narrative a user story to describe the
experience you want to develop or maybe
some people really like to start with
wire frames they just have layer frames
in their brain and they have to get them
out on paper it's all fine the important
thing is to then develop it and get into
a feedback loop with the people that are
that will use it in whatever form you're
going to do it that's been my experience
that was there another yeah yeah oh yeah
yes in the beginning most really what
happened after people that you can
corroborate it or keep it so they do you
think that if you create medicine for
comedic exploration composition
expressiveness is that enough what do
you need all the techniques you bring
people to the community first I don't
think there's one answer to that but I
can tell you is in general and again
this is in general there's exceptions to
this in general what I found is that
during on what thinking of onboarding is
more of a single player experience tends
to be better because a lot of times
people are wary of interacting with
other people until they're comfortable
in an environment now you can think of a
lot of counter examples to that likes a
facebook but most times when your
onboarding someone you it's like I'll
make maps for my clients of Express
explore compete and collaborate and
we'll have the first thing will be
explorer like the very first thing is
usually explore like when you're on boys
like what can I do here what
there to see what content is there to
consume blah blah blah right and then
what you want to do if you're really
smart is get them a little bit into self
expression but it can be as simple as
you know putting some information it can
be sometimes customizing an avatar
choosing a background anything like that
that's a trick designers use to get
people to feel more involved in the
system without actually confronting them
with social interaction which is just
you have to be more comfortable but so
explore and express or really good
things to do during onboarding giving
people a sense of progression so
sometimes like you people use progress
bars people use badges people just use
feedback to say you know this is what we
want you to do minecraft for onboarding
has survival mode which is very clever
where you're just you have to figure out
how to survive or you die and they have
no built-in tips you go out on the
internet and you look up the minecraft
wiki and then you find out you know what
to do so collaboration and competition
usually come later and you might want to
during onboarding introduce people to
that and maybe explain it and sometimes
there's ways to do that by showing them
the results of other people's
collaborations first is getting them to
collaborate themselves but in general I
found there are certain situations where
you you do want to be if your if your
experience is fundamentally competitive
like fela League of Legends you want to
get into that pretty soon but even
before you get into competition they
need to learn the ropes and learning the
ropes you can have social interaction
but it's much much easier to design a
single player experience so that's what
most people do the last game i worked on
that's what we did onboarding was a
single player experience it was defined
that way and then once you had gotten
through that and you were sort of hooked
then we introduced the in that case
collaborative mechanics yes summer and
start up here after you talked about I
when you lose peace and happiness and
I'm curious social compares it's what I
said specific okay so
fires and leads to unhappiness and I
wonder if a little bit of that also
happens with these cooperative platforms
and what you can do about it so for
instance on Kickstarter I looked at a
month of Kickstarter projects and a lot
of them had very very few people
contributed right if I one of those
creators who had four of my friends
being only people who contributed to my
project that's a pretty bad game for me
unless you would set your goal so low
that meant success but if you set your
goal higher and you didn't succeed then
you didn't succeed then they hide to the
finding gold and they have it will be
over rights okay what I guess designed
to us do you think I think there's any
design tool that can solve that problem
honestly I don't think that's a problem
that can be solved with that Weaver the
thing there to meet like as a designer
that to me that problem is helping the
person understand why they didn't
succeed and offering them timely best
practices to help them succeed that
would be the way that as a designer I
would tackle that not try and make them
feel better the fact is they failed but
and so sugarcoating failure in general
isn't useful what when I said social
comparison leads to unhappiness both
studies the punchline of those studies
just to get very specific about that is
that they did studies about what people
pay attention to and then showing them
different kinds of things like showing
them how much they got better compared
to their old self and their old
performance versus showing that how are
you they were doing in response to other
people and comparing yourself to other
people is a game that you can never win
basically and it's like what we see I
mean we all live here in Silicon Valley
and you know if you are always comparing
yourself there's always somebody richer
there's always somebody younger and more
successful you know there will always be
and as soon as you get your Maserati and
your first
two million you start comparing yourself
to the guy with the 10 million and if
you go that route you'll just always be
doing that right and so you know there's
this finding from the labs there's the
intuitive observations that we can all
have and then there's what do we want to
build into our games and the fact is
kickstarter doesn't have a leaderboard
and part of why they don't have a
leaderboard is a don't want to promote
that but it's a part of the system
itself i'm actually dealing with us
right now with indiegogo who's one of my
clients which is what do we do about all
the disgruntled failures and there's a
lot of them and you know and i think the
thing you do is you help them understand
why they didn't succeed and what they
could do differently in the future to be
more successful patients and you know my
sense of the landscapes of ours that
maybe like its students emerging but i
think it remains to be seen whether it's
going to be successful or not and your
team of games like they're really a form
of escape at their farm enjoyment unless
you ever really want to think about it
your help so I'm just curious of any
predictions about where that hole feels
is going and how successful it might be
so I think there's a ton so it's going
to be successful in tracking better
tracking better feedback systems so you
know some people again gave it to me the
word gamification is just just
meaningless and the often misleading but
is there going to be better designed
applications that give patients more
autonomy better feedback absolutely and
I see a ton of interesting stuff you
know self-tracking stuff where someone
who's diabetic can get better you know
better data that shows them you know
where their trouble spots are that are
based on a month's worth of analysis
better you know I see some stuff going
on with AI systems that can really help
with diagnosis I think that stuff's
really interesting there's a whole
industry emerging around add-ons to
iphone cases of you you're probably
aware of this I saw that it vinod khosla
showed me that stuff he's way into it
and you know you can stick a thing on
your iPhone a case that can measure your
heartbeat that you know can be used to
help people manage their own health so
if you think of good feedback as a form
of gamification then absolutely I think
better feedback is great and also just
better transparency in the healthcare
field but do I think points and badges
are going to solve health care's
problems you can probably guess what my
answer would be right now so I think
there's a lot of wrongheaded stuff going
on and I also think there's a lot of
interesting stuff going on but again you
know it's interesting to see with the
zero-sum nonzero-sum there's this one
company I forget their name and I
probably shouldn't say it publicly even
if so but it's a it's one of the many
many companies that's gamifying exercise
there's a ton of them okay and they sent
me up the CEOs have you a personal note
amy-jo you're so esteemed in the field
you're a guru I want your feedback I
know you're going to love our new app
and I look at it and what do I see
compete taunt you know kill yeah it just
it just like like a parody of zero-sum
mechanics and I sent him an email back
and I said have you considered
collaborative mechanics he's like oh
we're going to get to that we're going
to get to that and it was just like I
wasn't I didn't want to open the app
because it turns me off I don't want a
punim of my opponents it's not
motivating to me so I think there's I
mean and I think they're probably going
to get up take with really competitive
males and frankly if I was designing a
system to get sales people of you know
internal sales people in an enterprise
app to perform I probably use 0 some
mechanics because it's already in their
culture it's already how they think
right so it just depends on what you're
doing I'm excited about the more
collaborative stuff and I do see more of
that two gentlemen here good you think
that cases where collaborative game
would not be
yeah that says yeah there's tons of
cases like i was i was thing like a
genuine risk on what a cooperative game
is tied into a collaborative no no it
depends on who your users are and what
motivates them comes down to that if
your mood if you have a user base that's
not motivated by collaboration then you
shouldn't do it so it really is that
simple how you use it how do you see
games that combine those things that you
have a team computing again against the
system and then you have leader force
about how they are doing comparative
well gee often an incredibly powerful
combination so there's many of my
clients and that's what we end up with
is that comet is basically a variation
on team sports so yeah that's if it's
appropriate that's really good it's you
know it's more infrastructure I mean the
thing you get it so how do I see it I
see it as great if it makes sense but
some clients of mine for instance don't
have the you know the funding to build
all that infrastructure so then you have
to make some hard choices but it's often
very very effective okay
you